عقب اعلانه التجربه الناجحه لصواريخ يبلغ
مداها 700 كيلومتر قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان قوات بلاده ستركز على العمليات
الهجوميه وبهذا المدى تستطيع اوكرانيا
استهداف مساحات واسعه داخل روسيا من بينها
العاصمه موسكو التي لا تبعد الى نحو 500
كيلومتر عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه وقد استاد
استهدفت بالفعل عده مقاطعات روسيه وفقا
لما تعلنه موسكو لاسيما في الشمال حيث
طالت الهجمات كورس وبالجورود وتولا
والعاصمه موسكو ووصلت هجمات الطائرات
المسيره في الشمال الى مطار بسكوف على بعد
800 كم من الحدود الاوكرانيه لكن السلطاتك
قالت ان تلك المسيرات اطلقت من داخل
الاراضي الروسيه في الشرق ايضا استهدفت
استهدفت مقاطعات روسيه عده من اهمها
روستوف وكريس نودار التي تبعد نحو 200
كيلومتر فقط من مناطق السيطره الاوكرانيه
في الجنوب ازدادت الهجمات في الاونه
الاخيره على شبه جزيره القرم المتنازع
عليها والتي لا تبعد عن مناطق السيطره
الاوكرانيه الا نحو 150 كيلومترا